es ist ein sehr französischer protest am
vergangenen wochenende in der nähe von
elke fischer aus allen teilen der
britannia kommen zusammen auf dem
speiseplan stehen meeresfrüchte und
widerstand gegen eine wie sie es sehen
bedrohung ihrer fanggründe damit
übertrieben
das wird alles zerstört alles zerstören
es geht um eine ökologische bedrohung
sie wollen löcher graben drei meter
durchmesser 20 bis 30 meter tief und
viele davon ein loch für jedes windrad
man will windanlagen direkt in unsere
fischerei zone setzen das betrifft vor
allem kleine fischer das bedroht uns wir
fürchten dass dieser eingriff und
zerstört sie protestieren an land und
auf dem meer
dieses erkundungs schiff soll den boden
bereiten für einen offshore-windpark
testen ob das gelände geeignet ist
seither tobt in der bucht von san bruno
der kampf gegen windmühlenflügel
wir haben eine schöne bucht voller
jakobsmuscheln und einem großen
fischreichtum ich bin 22 jahre alt mir
macht das die angst vor der zukunft
real ist einer der wortführer der
hiesigen fischer sie sind zumeist auf
kleinen booten unterwegs sind können
nicht allzu weit hinaus früher erklärt
warum sie die windenergieanlagen als
bedrohung empfinden das blaue da sind
muschel käfige die wir jeden tag
anlaufen und an bord holen
die roten punkte stehen für die
geplanten windkraftanlagen die arbeiten
genau in diesem bereich sollte sich
unser material darin verheddern
dann ist das gefährlich für das boot es
kann leicht kentern oder das material
wird zerstört
an land in kiel haben gleichwohl die
arbeiten begonnen um die energie an land
zu bringen
der energiebedarf von 850.000 anwohnern
könnte durch die 62 windkraftanlagen
gedeckt werden
jede bis zu 200 meter hoch wie in dieser
projektion der betreiber sagt das ganze
werde die fischerei nicht nachhaltig
schädigen
dieser standort wurde gemeinsam mit
vertretern der fischereiindustrie
ausgewählt wir haben eine ausschreibung
gewonnen
wir haben die gespräche fortgesetzt um
einen windpark einzurichten der die
fischerei ermöglicht und die
auswirkungen auf die umwelt begrenzt
cathrin puhl soll beruhigt das nicht sie
marschiert mit bei den protesten fußball
ist umweltaktivisten warum kämpfen
ausgerechnet umweltschützer gegen
windkraft grüne energie ist gut aber man
sollte dafür nicht eine geschützte bucht
zerstören und die sehr reichhaltige
biodiversität alle lieben doch korallen
ist es nicht widersprüchlich für
windkraft zu sein aber sie nicht vor der
eigenen haustür haben zu wollen
es geht nicht darum sie nicht bei sich
haben zu wollen es geht darum dass
dieses projekt an einem falschen ort
entstehen sollen
so geht das an vielen standorten kein
wunder dass gerade mal acht prozent der
energie in frankreich mit wind erzeugt
wird deutlich weniger als in deutschland
etwa windkraft und die entwicklung der
windenergie in frankreich sind sehr
wichtig wir müssen erneuerbare energien
in unserem land voranbringen
wir sind da im rückstand sehr sogar im
vergleich zu anderen europäischen
ländern ein aufholen ist ein weiter weg
zurückzulegen windkraft in frankreich
erregt sich nicht nur bei fischern und
umweltschützern protest die stadtarchiv
fürchtet um besucher und meldet soziale
bedenken an
wissen sie welches das grandioseste
spektakel hier ist und auch noch
kostenlos und für jeden zugänglich
unabhängig vom sozialen status
das ist der sonnenuntergang am abend am
kap von und das nimmt man uns nun weg
windkraft als ästhetische zumutung auch
wenn das forschungsschiff und die
windanlagen weit draußen liegen an
frankreichs küsten tun sich abgründe auf
ich mache gerne fotos mich würden
windräder da stören
das macht ein bisschen die landschaft
kaputt
und überall da wo proteste aufflackern
finden sich in frankreich schnell auch
die ein die sie anfangen und sich daran
erwärmen wollen
windräder sind eine echte katastrophe
sie sind eine optische katastrophe eine
ökologische katastrophe und eine
ökonomische katastrophe
und wenn das projekt von emanuel macros
regierung voranschreitet wird das
katastrophale konsequenzen für die
lebensqualität unserer bürger haben ein
grund dass frankreich sich solchen
widerstand erlauben kann ist dass der
strom auch ohne erneuerbare aus der
steckdose kommt die regierung setzt
trotz aller bekenntnisse zur windkraft
weiter auf eine andere quelle
unsere zukunft was energie und umwelt
betrifft ist auf atomkraft aufgebaut
atomkraft produziert keine abgase und
ist sicher fischerei und fortschritt der
kampf gegen windmühlen rührt und
grundfesten der französischen identität
unumstritten energie und sechs weiteren
standorten an der bretonischen küste ist
derzeit wohl nur diese form der
windenergie
[Musik]